JOE BIDEN ABROAD.
THAT AREAS TOMORROW AT 9:00 P.M.
EASTERN RIGHT HERE ON CNN.
DON'T MISS IT.
>>> ONE DAY BEFORE PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S VISIT TO SELMA, ALABAMA,
HIS PREDECESSOR HEADLINED THE
CONSERVATIVE POLITICAL ACTION
CONFERENCE IN MARYLAND JUST
OUTSIDE OF WASHINGTON.
OVER THE COURSE OF NEARLY TWO
HOURS, FORMER PRESIDENT DONALD
TRUMP LASHED OUT AT BIDEN AND
MANY REPUBLICANS, BEMOANED
ONGOING INVESTIGATIONS INTO
HIMSELF, VOWED HE WON'T DROP OUT
OF THE RACE EVEN IF HE'S
INDICTED, AND SIGNALED HOW HE
MIGHT CAMPAIGN IN THE COMING
MONTHS TO BE ELECTED AGAIN.
HERE'S WHAT HE SAID.
>> IN 2016, I DECLARED I AM YOUR
VOICE.
TODAY I ADD, I AM YOUR WARRIOR.
I AM YOUR JUSTICE.
AND FOR THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN
WRONGED AND BETRAYED, I AM YOUR
RETRIBUTION.
I AM YOUR RETRIBUTION.
>> JOINING ME NOW, FORMER TRUMP
WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY
STEPHANIE GRISHAM AND OLIVIA
TROYE, A FORMER ADVISER TO VICE
PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE.
STEPHANIE, LET ME START WITH
YOU.
YOU KNOW, IT'S SO EASY TO BLOW
OFF TRUMP'S BLUSTER AND SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT HE SAYS.
BUT WHEN HE TALKS ABOUT
RETRIBUTION AND TALKING ABOUT
REVENGE, WHAT DID YOU MAKE OF
THAT?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, IT'S
SOMETHING I'VE BEEN SAYING FOR
QUITE A WHILE, THAT THIS IS
GOING TO BE A REVENGE TOUR FOR
THE FORMER PRESIDENT.
BUT, YOU KNOW, I WONDERED
SPECIFICALLY WITH REGARD TO WHAT
HE SAID, WHO DECIDES WHO NEEDS
THE RETRIBUTION?
WHO'S GOING TO DECIDE WHO'S BEEN
MISTREATED?
I MEAN WHAT ABOUT ALL THE PEOPLE
WHO SUFFERED OR HAD FAMILY
MEMBERS PASS AWAY FROM COVID?
ARE YOU GOING TO BE RETRIBUTION
FOR THAT?
YOU HAD A HAND IN THAT.
SO I THINK IT WAS, AS YOU JUST
SAID, A LOT OF BLUSTER FOR HIM.
BUT IT'S WHAT HIS BASE WANTS TO
HEAR, AND I THINK IT'S SOMETHING
THAT SHOULD BE TAKEN SERIOUSLY.
A LOT OF PEOPLE RIGHT NOW, I
THINK, ARE ROLLING THEIR EYES
AND SAYING THAT'S JUST TRUMP
BEING TRUMP.
BUT THIS IS IMPORTANT.
WE NEED TO REALLY PAY ATTENTION
TO WHAT HE'S SAYING AND REALIZE
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GET THE SAME
DONALD TRUMP.
WE'RE GOING TO GET A MORE ANGRY
AND VENGEFUL DONALD TRUMP IF HE
SHOULD TAKE OFFICE.
>> RIGHT, IF THAT'S EVEN
POSSIBLE.
AND OLIVIA, SPEAKING EARLIER
THIS PAST WEEK WITH CBS NEWS,
YOUR FORMER BOSS, MIKE PENCE,
TWICE DECLINED TO COMMIT TO
SUPPORTING DONALD TRUMP.
THAT WAS NOTABLE, IF HE'S THE
GOP NOMINEE.
LISTEN TO WHAT HE HAD TO SAY.
>> WELL, I THINK WE'LL HAVE
BETTER CHOICES, AND I REALLY
TRUST REPUBLICAN VOTERS TO SORT
IT OUT.
>> YEAH, THAT'S NOT REALLY
COMMITTING TO SUPPORTING TRUMP.
WHAT DID YOU THINK OF THAT,
OLIVIA?
>> WELL, I THINK -- YOU KNOW,
THE REALITY IS THAT IS WHERE THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY IS.
LIKE STEPHANIE SAID, I DON'T
DISCOUNT TRUMP.
HE IS THE FRONT-RUNNER.
I THINK PENCE IS HOPING, HEY,
I'M A BETTER CHOICE.
THE CHOICE IS ME.
AND I STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT HE
WILL RUN.
BUT I THINK THE REALITY IS THAT
THE PAST VICTORY THERE IN THE
REPUBLICAN LANE IS VERY NARROW
FOR THESE OTHER CANDIDATES
OUTSIDE OF TRUMP.
AND I THINK THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
NEEDS TO DECIDE WHETHER THEY'RE
WILLING TO SUPPORT SOMEONE ELSE
AND REALLY BACK THAT CANDIDATE.
>> AND I GUESS I WANT TO ASK YOU
BOTH JUST AS A FOLLOW-UP TO
THAT, I MEAN CAN YOU BELIEVE
WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW, COMING
OUT OF CPAC, WHERE DONALD
TRUMP -- OBVIOUSLY HE WON THE
UNSCIENTIFIC STRAW POLL AT CPAC,
BUT HE'S LEADING IN ALL OF THE
POLLS.
STEPHANIE, AS HIS FORMER WHITE
HOUSE SECRETARY, AND I KNOW YOU
DON'T WANT TO SEE HIM BACK IN
THE OVAL OFFICE EVER AGAIN, ARE
YOU AT ALL SURPRISED THAT TRUMP
IS IN THIS POSITION WHERE HE --
I MEAN LARRY HOGAN DECIDED TODAY
HE'S NOT GOING TO RUN.
THERE AREN'T A LOT OF TAKERS IN
TERMS OF WANTING TO TAKE ON
DONALD TRUMP.
HE MAY GET THIS NOMINATION
AGAIN.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THAT?
>> WELL, I'M OBVIOUSLY NOT
HAPPY, AND I HAVE COMMITTED TO
DOING ALL I CAN TO TRY AND
ENSURE THAT THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN
BY JUST TALKING TO PEOPLE AND
EDUCATING PEOPLE ON WHO HE
REALLY IS.
BUT, YOU KNOW, I THINK THAT WHAT
ASA HUTCHINSON DID WAS SMART.
I THINK HE REALLY SAW THAT HE
HAD NO PATH TO VICTORY, AND I
THINK -- WELL, I HOPE --
>> LARRY HOGAN.
>> I'M SORRY, YES.
I THINK OTHER PEOPLE WHO ARE
WANTING TO MAYBE JUMP INTO THE
RACE, I HOPE THEY HAVE THAT KIND
OF LOOK-WITHIN MOMENT BECAUSE,
AGAIN, AS WE'VE ALL TALKED ABOUT
MANY TIMES, BACK IN 2016, THE
REASON TRUMP WON THE PRIMARY WAS
BECAUSE THE FIELD WAS SO BIG.
I DO BELIEVE IF SOMEBODY LIKE
RON DeSANTIS GETS IN, IT'S EARLY
YET, SO THESE POLLS -- I KNOW
THEY DO HAVE TRUMP AHEAD, BUT I
DO BELIEVE IF SOMEBODY REALLY
GETS IN AND IS WILLING TO TAKE
HIM ON, I THINK THERE'S A
FIGHTING CHANCE THERE.
BUT I'M DEFINITELY WORRIED.
I'M DEFINITELY CONCERNED ABOUT,
YOU KNOW, HOW STRONG HE IS STILL
AFTER EVERYTHING THAT PEOPLE
HAVE SEEN OVER AND OVER.
>> OLIVIA, STEPHANIE MENTIONED
RON DeSANTIS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
DO YOU THINK HE COULD
POTENTIALLY KNOCK TRUMP OUT OF
THIS SPOT THAT HE'S IN RIGHT
NOW, WHICH REALLY HE'S THE
FRONT-RUNNER RIGHT NOW.
HE'S THE MAN TO BEAT.
I KNOW THERE'S A LONG WAY TO GO,
BUT I MEAN MANY PEOPLE CONSIDER
THE FLORIDA GOVERNOR THE
STRONGEST OPPONENT TRUMP COULD
FACE FOR THE NOMINATION.
BUT DO YOU THINK HE COULD KNOCK
HIM OUT OF THAT SPOT?
>> I THINK IT WILL BE VERY HARD.
I THINK ONCE DeSANTIS GETS
GOING, I DON'T THINK HE'S AS
APPEALING.
HE DOESN'T HAVE THE CHARISMA, SO
TO SPEAK, THAT TRUMP HAS, THAT
KIND OF DRAW, THAT FIERY BRAND,
I WOULD SAY.
I ACTUALLY DON'T SEE THE TWO OF
THEM AS BEING DIFFERENT PEOPLE.
I KNOW THAT MANY OF MY
REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES WILL SAY,
OH, DeSANTIS IS SO MUCH BETTER.
I DON'T SEE HIS POLITICS AS VERY
DIFFERENT THAN TRUMPISM.
HE IS TRUMPISM.
HE'S JUST, YOU KNOW, GOT A
DIFFERENT CLOAK WRAPPED AROUND
HIM.
BUT I THINK IT'S A POSSIBILITY.
DO I SEE IT?
NOT RIGHT NOW.
>> AND, STEPHANIE, TRUMP SAID
YESTERDAY TO REPORTERS THAT HE'S
GOING TO RUN AGAIN NO MATTER
WHAT, EVEN IF HE'S INDICTED.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS?
DO YOU THINK THAT THERE'S A
CHANCE THAT WE WILL SEE AN
INDICTMENT OF DONALD TRUMP, OR
DID THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT,
VARIOUS AUTHORITIES JUST KIND OF
MISS THEIR CHANCE TO DO THAT, TO
BRING AN INDICTMENT?
>> WELL, I DON'T WANT TO SAY
THAT THEY MISSED THEIR CHANCE.
AS WE ALL KNOW, THE WHEELS OF
JUSTICE MOVE VERY, VERY SLOW.
AND I DO BELIEVE TRULY THAT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WANTS TO DO
THIS THE RIGHT WAY.
I DON'T BELIEVE WE'RE GOING TO
SEE HIM GET INDICTED.
I REALLY DON'T.
I THINK THAT AT THIS POINT, IT
WILL ALL JUST BE POLITICAL,
POLITICAL, POLITICAL ACCORDING
TO, YOU KNOW, THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
BUT TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION, THE
FACT THAT HE SAID THAT, YOU
KNOW, HE WOULD CONTINUE TO RUN
EVEN IF INDICTED, THAT DID NOT
SURPRISE ME AT ALL.
THAT WAS PRIME TRUMP.
HE'S DOUBLING DOWN.
THIS IS HOW HE SAYS HE'S
COMPLETELY INNOCENT.
AND HE JUST, YOU KNOW -- HE
DOESN'T CARE ABOUT THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
HE DOESN'T CARE.
HE GETS AWAY WITH EVERYTHING, SO
WHY WOULD HE BE SUDDENLY LIKE,
I'M GOING TO DROP OUT?
>> OLIVIA, FINAL THOUGHT TO YOU.
>> YEAH, WHAT ARE WE GOING TO
HAVE?
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE DONALD
CORLEONE RUNNING FOR THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES?
THIS IS EMBARRASSING IF HE DOES
GET INDICTED, AND THAT WOULD BE
THE CASE.
I AGREE WITH STEPHANIE.
I SEE HIM DOUBLING DOWN.
LOOK, THERE'S A REASON THAT JIM
JORDAN AND ALL THESE REPUBLICANS
ON THE HILL HAVE THIS
WEAPONIZATION OF THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT.
THAT IS ALL IN MY OPINION PART
OF THE STRATEGIC PLAN OF HOW
THEY WILL SPIN THIS.
>> ALL RIG